good morning believe nation today's
message is put in the effort order you a
Lewis there's not a person on my team in
16 years that is consistently beat me to
the ball every play I think I'm gonna do
a talent that's just got everything to
do it effort nothing else 15 straight
years 12 Pro Bowls later if you want
numbers that's all of it
and the only thing that's kept me around
it's my effort so you put on this all I
ever knew because I won the number one
recruit I won the number one lie back I
won't even in the media guy all I ever
knew was effort will get me seen on the
tape effort and get me notice to get to
the lead effort but one day take care my
mom and my kids effort which is between
you and you nobody else can give you a
flea health efforts with inside man
so anything well I think putting the
effort and anything is very important
and definitely more important than
getting fixated on what other people
think about you even he haven't put that
for so far like a good example was
actually myself when I first came to
this country outside
and people really picked on me okay
chica I ran there right yeah people
picked on me on the way I spoke and and
instead of getting the security about
what they say and just just kind of
going to my own corner I started
watching a lot of movies I started
getting outside of my personal bubble
and speaking to people no matter how
silly I sounded and and that right now
my English is much better than it was
before I'm not saying I'm a motivational
speaker or anything but uh I would say
I've approved more than I would have
thought or if I haven't though when my
mom came from Italy she didn't know any
English and she watched movies too as a
way that learned English and now I we
get a lot of comments below from people
saying that they learn English by
watching these videos so that's like a
full circle moment it's really cool I
love this message I think if you look at
my own experience I've never been the
most talented and whatever I was doing
it was just by putting in the effort and
being consistent one of the comments
that I always get about my youtube
channel is the consistency right we're
putting up mostly three videos a day
every single day not always on the
weekends but almost every single day
will respond to every single comment on
the channel and it's it's just a lot of
work it's a lot of grinding it's a lot
of effort right I sucked when I first
got on camera where you can go back to
my channel look at the first videos I
was really really bad I took I see other
people who are starting now and look at
their first videos and I look at where
they are for like 20 videos and there's
so much further ahead then I was up to
20 videos and they look at their
progress and they're like I'm so so bad
I'm still not I'm not good enough and
and they want to quit and give up and it
blows my mind because
I was just so much worse than they were
and the thing that got me to was just
another video another video in another
video and we put almost 3,000 videos up
on the channel that all them are public
that's 3,000 videos worth of practice
that most people can't keep up with and
so whatever it is that you want to get
better at you know expect the socket the
start is something new is something that
you're trying for the first time so you
are gonna suck at it and the way to get
better is to just keep practicing to
practicing and practicing every day get
a little bit better a little bit better
a little better but putting the effort
can overcome any mountain regardless of
how skilled and talented you are
the answer is hard work so the question
today today is how could you do
something different to motivate yourself
on putting that what are you going to do
differently to motivate yourself to put
in the effort leave in the comments
below will join the discussion thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso